[Musique]
je vous remerci de me donner l'occasion
de présenter mes vœux les plus sincères
à tous les ivelinoises toutes les
ivelinoises pardon et tous les ivelinois
une année qui évidemment pour nous outre
les réalités quotidiennes qui ne sont
pas toujours simples sera marqué par les
Jeux Olympiques bien entendu qui pour
festif qu'ils seront apporteront
évidemment quelques désagrément mais je
voudrais rassurer tout de suite les
usagers de la route des transports et
les résidents des communes
principalement
concerné ce qui va être confirmé dans
les jours prochains par mes
collaborateurs sera des restrictions
certes pendant les jours des épreuves
mais les plus limités possibles limité
si possible autant des épreuves et en
tenant compte des réalités de la vie
économique de la vie sociale de la vie
de tout un chacun donc Monsieur le
Préfet de police a pris des dispositions
extrêmement cadrées notamment pour Paris
compte tenu de l'enjeu notamment de la
cérémonie d'ouverture mais nous avons de
la nous avons la faculté de desserer un
petit peu les contraintes en tout cas
dans le temps et sur les lieux et nous
allons nous attacher par un dialogue
avec notamment les maires les présidents
de PCI et les parlementaires bien sûr et
les usagers la CCI la CMA nous allons
nous employer disje à réduire les
contraintes pour l'ensemble des
ivelinoises et des ivelinois donc ça
c'est une échéance évidemment très
importante pour le reste bien sûr la
préoccupation principale surtout après
les moments des émeutes aussi tragiques
que nous avons vécu fin juin début
juillet c'est la sécurité des personnes
et des bien et croyez bien et je les
salue que les services de police de
gendarmerie de renseignement mais
service propres ainsi que les polices
municipales naturellement sont
particulièrement mobilisés dans cet
esprit de vigilance
d'anticipation pour assurer la sécurité
de tous à cette sécurité qui est le bien
le bien le plus précieux que que nous
avons est je dirais construite jour
après jour aussi et on les oublie
souvent par les services de
renseignement et je voudrais dire qu'une
des
tâch que N nous assignons pour les temps
qui viennent surtout après les drames
qui se sont produits notamment récemment
à haras et à Paris c'est de prévenir
autant que possible je dis bien autant
que possible avec toutes les diligences
qui sont faites par la justice par les
services d'accompagnement sociaux
notamment l'aide sociale à l'enfance du
conseil départemental les service de
l'État la PGJ d'accompagner autant que
possible les personnes qui n'étant ni
hospitalisé en en établissement
psychiatrique ni
incarcéré
ont un
passé lourd et complexe mais que la
justice
a par définition en appliquant la
loi laissé libre mais qui ont accompli
dans le passé des actes tel que nous les
surveillons avec autant de diligence que
nécessaire
c'est un point qui se fait dans la plus
grande discrétion mais je tiens à saluer
particulièrement aujourd'hui toutes les
femmes et tous les hommes qui concourent
à accompagner là aussi ces personnes qui
parfois ont été la victime de
l'engagement criminel de leurs parents
sur le théâtre syrien et irakien ou de
l'endoctrinement d'autres personnes mais
croyez-moi c'est un
travail
au cas par cas de coups humains qui
nécessite l'engagement et il est grand
de beaucoup de fonctionnaires de l'État
des collectivités et des collectivitésal
et de la fonction publique hospitalière
d'ailleurs et de façon générale en
présentant ses vœux je forme le souhait
que les uns et les autres gardent la
raison la bonne foi qui doit tous nous
animer pour envisager cette année sans
tout en minimisant les violences qui
pourrait verbalement et puis dans la
réalité se manifester nous devons plus
que jamais par un
travail généreux de disponibilité
généreux ça veut dire créer des emplois
accompagner les entreprises
l'installation de France travail et les
promesses qui
l'accompagne travail généreux ça veut
dire aussi être capable dans l'éducation
nationale et dans toutes les formes
d'enseignement d'accompagner des élèves
qui sont parfois en
désarroi tout cela suppose de construire
concrètement autant que possible et
notamment dans nos quartiers dit de
politique de la ville la fraternité au
quotidien c'est vraiment l'exigence que
nous devons avoir en tête nous autres
responsables politique publique ou de
politique publique n'oublions jamais cet
élément du fronton de nos mairies nos
préfectures liberté égalité fraternité
je crois que plus que jamais nos
compatriotes aspirent à un apaisement du
débat public à la réalité du débat la
liberté d'expression est totale et vous
observerez qu'elle a été scrupuleusement
respectée dans le département des
Yvelines lors de toutes les
manifestations possibles mais encadré de
façon appro prié par les forces de
l'ordre donc liberté bien entendu mais
dans un cadre républicain recherche de
la fraternité par tous les moyens et
d'abord les moyens qui sont le respect
de la vérité le respect des personnes la
dignité du débat et l'attention portée à
chacun voilà Mesdames et Messieurs Chers
Compatriotes yvelinois ce que je nous
souhaite cette année sera forcément
complexe nous mesurons les difficultés
de logement les difficultés de
transport les difficultés de
l'hébergement d'urgence les problèmes
qui peuvent être posé ici et là par des
personnes en migration croyez que mes
collaborateurs et moi nous nous
attachons à leur résolution en accord
préalable en anticipant avec les élus et
les associations et les entreprises je
vrais enfin donc saluer les trois
catégories de personnes particulières
que je viens d'évoquer les élus de la
République les chefs d'entreprise les
responsables associatifs qui sont
vraiment les garants avec les
fonctionnaires des collectivités de la
fonction publique hospitalière et de
l'état de cette de ce
maillage pour assurer
au mieux le le bonheur et la fraternité
de nos compatriotes c'est un chemin
complexe car le monde dans lequel nous
vivons est chahuté violent
pre faisons l'effort de conjuguer tout
notre bon toutes nos bonnes volontés
dans le département de des ivelines pour
échapper autant que possible à cette
violence et construire ensemble la
fraternité je vous
[Musique]
remercie